hi eric singer dialect coach the map
tour of north american accents continues
[Music]
if you missed parts one and two you can
check them out here we're diving into
part three from the west
let's talk about california let's talk
about
southern california another part of the
country where we have some really
exciting ongoing change
so just like in some contemporary
english accents a more open oral posture
a lower jaw is lowering some vowel
sounds
most noticeably the dress and trap
vowels there are a bunch of vowel sounds
moving around here
goose and goat can both be very fronted
and the short e vowel the kit
vowel is being split in two for ng
it's likely to sound like e so thing
going just like the rest of the west but
otherwise it's lowered like dress and
trap
so bid gets closer to bed
miss begins to sound like mess and so on
so of course if you take this accent on
like turn the dial up to 11 we're
talking about a stereotypical surfer
accent like sort of a bill and ted's
kind of thing
you can hear that in a clip here when
they say excellent that's a lower dress
vowel
excellent excellent excellent
it's very much change in progress so
stay tuned
and of course la county has the highest
latinx population in the country
so i'm going to turn this over to meghan
again hi again
now i'm going to talk about chicano
english the majority of chicano english
speakers reside in the u.s southwest in
california and in chicago
chicano english is heavily influenced by
mexican spanish spanish
has been in this region longer than
english has in 1848 mexico ceded this
land to the u.s
because of this history mexican spanish
has been influencing the english of the
area for a really long time
one of my favorite features is devoicing
of word final z
so the sound z is a voiced sound you can
actually tell if you put your fingers
here right by your throat and you do the
z
sounds you'll feel vibration with the
voicing
we use the voiceless equivalent which is
an s
so the z sounds at the end of words turn
into more of an s sound
you can hear this devoicing in the
plural form or chair
chairs becomes chairs you can hear that
feature here
he did things he did things he did
things
another remarkable feature of chicano
english is that there's less vowel
reduction
so it's a little subtle but i'll try to
show you how it sounds
i say because and someone who would
reduce the vowel would say
because i say together and someone
reduced the vowel to
together today today
you can hear the features in this native
speaker clip to here you don't want to
listen to everyone
thanks megan while we're in the
southwest with chicano english let's
make a quick stop in the navajo nation
kalina on this stop we will be visiting
the traditional homelands of the navajo
people in the four corners area
the same devoicing feature found in
chicano english can also be found in
navajo english
you can hear a native speaker here i
want him to recognize
all indian tribes the second feature
here is a glottal replacement
of final consonants you can hear the
glottal stop instead of a t
i wanted to hear back to eric thank you
kalina
next up here's nicole to talk about
african-american language in california
we know that african-americans in
california participate in local features
such as ooh fronting and up talk you can
hear that here
uh i'm a monty dorn dorin dorn tuesdays
too soon to do that tuesdays tuesdays
a 2016 study found bat retraction or the
a vowel being pronounced further back in
the mouth
among bakersfield african americans you
can hear that in this clip
i'll be right back and then we can stack
those boxes
right back right back and now the map
tour continues with eric
as we move north from california up in
the pacific northwest we've definitely
got that caught caught merger they sound
the same up here
just like they do everywhere in the west
and in canada but one thing you hear a
lot up here is a lip rounded vowel for
it
oh so here we might talk about a hot pot
oh there's a little pocket around san
francisco that
doesn't have the cot caught merger by
the way so
unlike the whole rest of california the
whole west coast really
cod and caught sound distinct here like
they do in most of the south and the
east
just a little dialect island up over the
border in vancouver
you'll hear that same lot rounding but
you'll also start to get
raising and tensing in the trap vowel
when it comes right before a gu
sound like in bag agriculture flag
similar to what you can hear over in
minnesota
speaking of minnesota again there's a
fascinating dialect pocket in alaska
the matanuska-susitna valley that can
sound uncannily like those broad
minnesota accents
a lot of people suddenly noticed this in
2008 when sarah palin the former
governor of alaska
shot to national fame as the republican
vice presidential nominee
you can see that here in this clip i
appreciate this privilege of being able
to be here and speak with americans
we want to keep our aaa bonding rating
in minnesota
it turns out that in the 1930s there was
a huge migration of farmers to the matsu
valley
from michigan minnesota and wisconsin
so that's how that happened okay back to
canada
now kalina's originally from the
northwest territories
let's go back to her there are nine
official languages spoken in the
northwest territories including north
slavey
which is a part of the athabascan
language family i'm inspired by the many
revitalization efforts by our people to
save our languages
for example language deaths in hawaii
this is where young people are immersed
in the language
every day with elders in the community
another revitalization method is a
translation of popular television shows
and movies into indigenous languages
because of all this
i have tremendous hope for both the
future of our native american languages
and of native american english
thank you kalina okay let's go to
toronto
and let's talk for just a minute about
probably the most famous canadian accent
feature there is
it's called canadian raising though you
may not have heard it called that but
you're probably familiar with
naboot yeah of course canadians aren't
actually saying
ut naboot what they're doing is raising
the start of the diphthong in words like
out
and about so that instead of it starting
very open
it's starting from somewhere in the
middle of the mouth
oh it only affects syllables that end in
an
unvoiced consonant so words like out
about
house mouth in words like how
now loud rouse canadians still use that
wide
ow diphthong canadian raising isn't only
in that class of words though the mouth
vowel
it also affects the price vowel in the
same way
so that the starting point of words like
right life
type mice can get raised too but words
like
rise five tied fly keep their full eye
diphthong you can hear the contrast
between both of those if i say something
like
that's a fine price for a brown house
so out in the atlantic provinces of
canada we'll hear
accents that are in some cases almost
unrecognizably different from what
you'll hear
in most of the rest of canada once again
isolation and length of time are the key
factors here
newfoundland accents are maybe the most
distinctly different of all
i'm giving this one a go even though
i've never done it before so
be gentle please your new fees now
there's lots of variation here of course
and most younger folks aren't going to
sound like this but this would be an
accent from the fair
southeast of newfoundland down below
saint john's
we could go on about this one all day
sounds a bit irish doesn't it
this part of newfoundland was in fact
settled by
irish people mostly from county wexford
there's quite a lot of reasons why this
particular old newfoundland accent
sounds irish
bow sounds of course intonation
aspiration
but you'll also hear the irish slit tea
what's a slit tea it's a t sound made
with a very soft closure at the tip of
the tongue
or not even really quite a full closure
at all there's a slit left for the air
to escape through
what that hit it
i could stay here all day but it's about
time to wrap this up
so let's dip back down across the border
back into the states
and end close to where we started in
north eastern new england
i remember that caught caught merger
well the whole western u.s has it in all
of canada
and so does this part of new england
goes down about as far as boston
rhode island doesn't generally have it
but here in maine you've got that caught
caught merger so all the vowel sounds
and those two big groups of words
emerged
they all sound like oh here you know
what doesn't all sound the same though
mary mary and mary now they do in my
normal accent
mary mary mary and the same is true for
almost all of north america
but most speakers up here still have
distinct pronunciations for all three
mary mary mary
even more interestingly at least in some
older folks speak still
the historical distinction between horse
and horse
is still preserved so if your horse
has a sore throat you might have a horse
horse you can still hear this
distinction in parts of ireland and
scotland and parts of the u.s south
but that's about it this is one of the
last places you'll hear it
and that's it that's our last stop so
listen let me just say again
this is not meant to be a comprehensive
tour of all north american accents
we try to be at least somewhat
representative and to include some
insights into how
and why accents might differ from place
to place
i sincerely want to thank all of the
linguists and language experts who've
helped out
and if you want to follow them here they
are one more time you can find me on
twitter at megandfigueroa
and you can also find me at my podcast
the vocal fries pod
you can find me on twitter i'm at mix
linguist
if you want to learn more about the gala
language and what i'm getting into
follow me on instagram
at sunrise show twitter at sunbasho or
sunmesho.com you can find me at
amanidorndialex.com
this video would have had to be about 10
times longer if it were really going to
be systematic and thorough
but these are some sounds i love and
some things i think are interesting
and i had a lot of fun sharing it with
you if i piqued your interest about
accents and variation here are some cool
resources for finding out more
and we'll throw some more in the
description below